c'est un moment historique puisque war
devient le deuxè vaisseau spatial habité
à se poser sur la Lune après les
ÉtatsUnis vitesse DESC m 5 4 3 2 1
atterrissage
Astron je m'apprête à commencer la
mission
princip je vit de la
GL vous Deez ramener votre astrona
module de commande le plus rapidement
possible
un gigantesque météore va
s'écraser retourne à l'atterrisseur le
plus rapidement possible réinitialiser
et redémarer le logiciel du module de
commande si l'opération échoue pour
quelque raison que ce soit il n'y aura
plus de tenta d'abarrage demand de
trajectoire de l'a de la PL
méé mise à feu mise à
feu danger
dévation la demande d'autorisation a ét
[Musique]
reeté j'ai sur la face visible de
la